murals have been around since people
first put brush to paper or rather to
wall but these paintings are in fact the
ultimate in customized wallpaper from
mock wood paneling to flocks of birds
and intricate flower patterns
Gunther host and Ingrid Sorenson from
Hamburg have been custom painting walls
for 18 years now I found my LA but cliff
ematic murals are about the entire room
which is what makes them so special
normally you just have a picture that
you can hang here or there but murals
can stay in place for centuries well go
on that to finish one depa at the
beginning of every project their
creators brainstorm on the pattern
together with the client the artist duo
have a team of ten to help them make the
vision a reality jobs can take from two
weeks to two months and cost around a
thousand euros per workday some motifs
take more time than others today one of
their regular clients comes to their
Hamburg studio heartwood freaky has
commissioned a range of works from the
team one grace is his home on the
upscale vacation island of zut off
Germany's North Sea coast esky pas
devant maloja wall paper painting offers
endless possibilities I can decide the
width of the motifs I could decide
whether they have joints or where they
start and end that's the best part is
that its exclusive if you me I'm ologist
want Vinny the moment I enter my house
on suit I feel happy and satisfied dan
binish of the moment and all so far too
free luckily 0 Anson and boast are among
a small number of artists in Germany to
have mastered this otherwise dying craft
wall paper painting is an art form in
its own right where each individual
sheet is painted by hand does feely
senator Payton mala highest in vibe the
toughest thing about her is having to be
patient I did it made my life a wall
paper painting comprises the same
patterns painted over and over again
combined dice it requires a lot of
artistic skill and intuition but above
all patients
goodwood the duo have worked on numerous
projects with Hamburg interior designer
Christiana malo she's observed a big
rise in demand for creative customized
wall design and she has an idea why that
is that's the dullness today's rapidly
changing society means people have a
need for a place to call home somewhere
individual that speaks to them the thin
hardening fun either for example you
might have a couple with a shared
apartment in Berlin she works in Zurich
and London and he spends the week
working in Munich so when they get
together back home in Berlin they
obviously like staying there they'll
prefer to invite friends over rather
than to go out on black sollozzo country
host and Ingrid's Aronson don't just
customize private spaces this year they
gave a casino and interior makeover with
an optical illusion that gave the venue
of far more spacious feel Jesus casino
Andrew big hat nick is on this the
ceilings at this casino and lubick
aren't that high yum what we painted a
dome on this plaster board which is only
three metres up well it was to simulate
extra height site and these are young
women the man we included in the picture
is the owner of course he's not
monitoring his staff from above so there
was laughter all around van rossum I
agree mind left I heard it
custom designed wall painting and almost
forgotten art now flourishing a new
you